Well
[Music
] Cristian Cásseres greets you with his
brief News Now report in Spanish.
The young woman who died in the
accident involving the former
Rangers player at Ibrox received the last goodbye
from her family and loved ones on
Thursday evening.  tonight is about
23-year-old central china who lost her life
along with her dog max now members of
the community are coming together to
walk in her name on saturday in town
square at 10am everyone is asked
to attend  i know you wear a
white bandana and avoid
any hair related clothing
friday afternoon
state legislators will meet in
carson city for a special session
governor steve se sala wants to provide
information on the state including
congressional seats  your office could
add more items to this agenda
and one of the favorite events of the
holiday season returned Thursday night
for special guests
try to include ring light that
shines again on the speedway this 2
and a half mile track is the largest in the
state with millions of lights to
enjoy last night it only received
veterans and their families but the
public will be able to enjoy this event
from  on Friday and we close with a
look at the weather forecast
we will have some breezes for Friday
but with many it is the temperatures
will be close to 80 degrees
however a hot weekend awaits us
to enjoy
outdoor activities the temperatures
will drop again  For the next week I am
Cristian Cásseres with your brief
informative of iris neon Spanish good
day